Запечена з яблуками качка,
домашня ковбаска, голубці…
Всі ці страви родина Черьомушкіних приготувала на Різдво.
А в Святвечір, як і годиться,
сідатимуть за пісний стіл, де головною буде кутя.
Її готують останньою.
Так готувала бабуся моя, мама,
і ми традиції бережемо.
Господар тим часом нарізає яблуко, як символ здоров’я родини.
Підготував зайву ложку та стакан води.
Так запрошує до святкового столу усіх померлих.
Хай спробують нашої куті,
порадуються за нас, як як ми тут живемо,
що ми дочекались, нарешті, за 300 років того томоса.
Традиції родини від Різдва до Різдва не змінюються…
А ось настрій справді святковий.
Сім’я радіє новинам зі Стамбула, де Вселенський патріарх
підписав томос про автокефалію,
а отже, про створення помісної української церкви.
Це свято, велике свято,
яке війде в історію українського народу навіки.
Довгі роки сім'я Черьомушкіних була прихожанами
Української православної церкви Московського Патріархату,
нині головного противника томоса.
Своє ставлення до церкви вони змінили від початку війни.
Кажуть, саме тоді помітили, що в храмах УПЦ МП
священики не лише правлять службу,
але й пропагують антиукраїнську політику.
Не схотів ходити до московського патріархату і старший син - Дмитро,
який одразу після Майдану зголосився добровольцем в АТО.
В Голосієво їздили.
То там збирають підписи проти геїв, то ще збирають підписи.
Зайдеш туди в бібілотеку, а там книжки одні,
то про Романових, то як Сталіна святим зробити,
то ще щось. Жуков - Святий Георгій.
Це що? Це нормальна духовна література?
Про що там людям можуть розказувати?
Діма - наш син - ніколи не хотів туди ходити,
тоді і я замислився. А ми вирішили тоді вирішили збудувати у себе.
Храм Автокефальної православної церкви, разом з іншими вірянами
Черьомушкіни будують у рідному селі Тарасівка неподалік Києва.
Були б гроші - вже звели б.
Попереду і оздоблення фасаду, і утеплення,і розпис.
Утім головне, що служби вже правлять.
І згадують ім’я Патріарха Варфоломія та митрополита Епіфанія.
Адже цей храм, як і всі храми
Української Автокефальної Православної Церкви та УПЦ Київського Патріархату,
тепер належать єдиній помісній Православній Церкві України.
Це так символічно сталося,
що напередодоні такого великого свята
Рождення Ісуса Христа
ми отримали велику ласку Божу
на поєднання зі своїми братами православними
і в тому наша сила.
Віряни кажуть, що єдину Православну церкву України
обов’язково визнають усі інші помісні церкви світу.
Хочуть також щоб до ПЦУ перейшла і місцева,
тарасівська громада Московського Патріархату.
Все буде залежити від священика,
якщо буде все продовжуватись так,
як було у Московських церквах,
про це неодноразово говорили усі,
то мені здається, що люди відвернуться
і будуть десь шукати собі
інші церкви, де їм затишно.
Це надзвичайна радість, але нічого не змінилось,
адже вважаю, що Бог один, один для всіх,
і треба поважати кожну віру,
але мати своє і цінувати своє.
І нам потрібно бути добрішими одне до одного.
Постала церква, і тепер вона визнана в усьому світі.
Так само як і держава наша.
Як ми є у своєму храмі, так ми є у державі.
Це найголовніше.
Родина Черьомушкіних має за що сварити нинішю владу.
Але те, що саме нинішній президент та Верховна Рада
вирішили багатовікову церковну проблему,
називають історичною подією.
Зовсім інакше останні події сприймають в іншій православній родині.
33-трирічний киянин Антон Федоренко
власноруч готує для родини 12 різдвяних страв,
які за традицією мають бути на столі.
Серед них також  - святкова качка.
Це індокачка. Будемо просто запікати її в рукаві,
Буде мед і томатна паста.
Вона теж дає гарну скоринку і гарний смак.
Всю цю смакоту родина Антона
їстиме після ранкової різдвяної служби.
Але святкувати отримання Україною томоса і створення ПЦУ вони не будуть.
Антон і його дружина Ірина є прочанами
Української православної церкви під керівництвом митрополита Онуфрія.
Родина категорично не погоджується, коли їхню церкву називають
"осередком руського миру", "церквою, яка фінансує війну проти України"
або "Московським патріархатом".
Від Москви ми фактично незалежні.
Ми самі вибираємо предстоятеля,
ми самі канонізуємо своїх святих.
Нам не треба благословення Москви для цього.
В новій структурі фактично все має вирішувати Константинополь.
Антон і Ірина не мають наміру переходити в новостворену церкву.
Кажуть: ідея нової соборної церкви,
яка об’єднала б усіх православних України,
так і не була реалізована.
А думку вірян найбільшої за чисельністю УПЦ
Московського патріархату - не врахували.
Прочани УПЦ МП досі називають вірян та священників
Київського патріархату і Української автокефальної церкви - "розкольниками".
Філарет мав би покаятися,
Макарій теж мав покаятися.
Мала бути створена одна структура в Україні,
яка вже потім просила собі автокефалію.
Зараз виходить розкольницька структура,
яку  типу узаконили,
тобто намагаються всі притягнути до себе,
сказати, ми тепер справжні, ідіть до нас. Це неправильно.
Це не в дусі Христа. Просто рейдерство фактично.
Якби не війна з Росією, церковне питання
вирішувалося геть по-іншому, нарікає Антон.
Та й держава дарма втрутилася в справи церкви.
В Храмі Святителя Спиридона різдвяну службу правлять церковнослов’янською.
В молитвах згадують митрополита Онуфрія,
главу Російської Православної церкви Кирила,
моляться і за українську владу – але без конкретних прізвищ.
Згадують і армію, яка захищає Україну.
Священик розмовляє з прочанами українською.
У храмі лунають українські колядки.
Під час цієї різдвяної служби знімальна група DW
не почула жодної згадки про томос.
Священик Миколай Данилевич вважає, що кількамісячних бурхливих дискусій
було досить, щоб знищити довіру населення до церкви.
Зараз це все надоїло, тому що...
Я вважаю, що це є певною проблемою саме для церкви,
стільки церковних питань було викинуто
в зовнішній світ, і відбулася певна така
десакралізація церкви. Тому що, якщо церква  була раніше дещо сакральне,
о тепер побачили, що там є якісь проблеми , якісь непорозуміння,
якісь сварки і тому подібне,
і зовнішній світ вважає, що церква це так саме, як у нас.
Наразі в Україні, за різними даними, існує
приблизно 7 000 приходів нової об’єднаної Православної церкви України
і 12 000 приходів Московського патріархату.
Чи чекати масової міграції до нової церкви,
Антон Федоренко не береться казати.
Каже, для багатьох вірян буде вирішальним,
чи визнають ПЦУ решта 14 православних церков світу.
Поки наш предстоятель не проповідує єдності,
тобто ми йдемо за нашим предстоятелем.
Поки вони дякують Богу за все, що мають,
і моляться, щоб сварки і непорозуміння між вірянами припинилися.
Та на це навряд можна сподіватися –
попереду розгортання конфлікту довкола
перейменування УПЦ МП.
Український парламент ухвалив закон про те, що відтепер вона має називатися
із зазначенням належності до Росії –
адже національна церква в державі має бути одна,
і віднині, за згодою Вселенського престолу,
це – Православна церква України.